Obviously, the pandemic,
but there's been so much other heaviness
going on in the last month.
I know that you'd been a activist
and a very active activist
for many, many years,
and you take this very seriously,
and I'm just curious,
how have the conversations been
in the wake of George Floyd's murder?
Were you and your family
having different conversations
than you've had before,
or was it more intense,
or did you feel like, no,
this didn't change anything for us,
we've known this for a long time.
Well, we've definitely had
these conversations before,
but I think everyone has felt
an intensity about this one
and it has been ratcheted up,
mainly because of the callousness
and the manner in which
the murder happened,
and how we were all locked down
and just watching it on a loop.
I mean, I never saw the
whole tape, actually.
I just saw the beginning and the end.
I couldn't really watch it.
But, yes, these conversations
have been had prior to this
with my family, with the community,
but with my kids, it was
definitely ratcheted up a lot more,
because, for them, my youngest anyway,
is really just getting into the workforce,
just beginning her life,
and really starting her
life as an adult out there,
and having all of these things
happen at the same time.
George Floyd was after Ahmaud Arbery,
was after Breonna Taylor,
was after even Amy Cooper in the park.
So, I think the confluence of
all of those things together,
with the pandemic on top of it,
really made this boiling point happen,
and then we saw the lid come off,
and, hopefully, we will
continue to find ways
to keep the conversation alive.
I know that there's still
protests, I mean, Portland,
it's still happening
all around the country,
all around the world really.
So it's not like people
have completely forgotten.
But human beings want to exhale.
They want to let that stress off
and go back to what
they believe is normal.
But I just think we can't do that now
because I think a return to what is normal
is actually a step back.
It won't be just a return,
it'll be a complete reset
to something that I don't
think we can afford to do
as a community, so, hopefully,
this moment is instructive
and, hopefully, we'll find
many, many different ways
to continue this conversation
and find out how we can really approach
this systematic issue
from all different angles.
There's a question I wanted to ask you
that I've been pondering a little bit,
which is the role of
celebrities in all of this.
I think it can, maybe, sometimes
get a little complicated
with celebrities.
100%.
And I think you feel the same way,
but I thought maybe we could
have a discussion about that.
My feeling being there's a very fine
between someone in the public
eye giving of themselves
and trying to move this piece forward,
and trying to help us all grow,
and saying, "hey, look
at me, check me out."
Yeah.
It can flip so quickly
and I just wanted to talk to you about it,
'cause I'm sure you have
a strong opinion about it.
Well, I agree with what you're saying.
I mean, it can be a double-edged sword.
We have this platform and
we're both sensitive people,
and we are a part of the world,
and we're understand that
though we have this ability
to, in some ways, insulate
ourselves from things.
At the same time, we are not insulated
and these issues affect everyone,
and, so, yes, we want
to take our platforms
and find ways to be productive
and find ways to actually
say move this thing forward.
But I think a lot of times
what it requires is for us
to kind of step out of the way
and use the power that
we have as producers,
as people behind the cameras,
as well as in front of the camera
to push it on that end,
and make sure that the
non-centered voices get centered,
people who are not seen
get to the front,
and something that I saw people were doing
on Twitter which I
thought was really cool,
was a lot of people were just
giving their platform over
to other people, you
have a million followers,
you're like, okay, now
let's check out Debbie
who's doing this with whatever,
or Jim who's doing this over here,
and they're just gonna have
my platform for awhile.
So, I think a lot of times
our best work is done
when we step out of the way.
Yeah.
We get the attention
and then we shift the
light, shift the focus,
and yeah, it's tricky
because you can look like
you're clout surfing,
you can look like you're
trying to go, look at me,
but I'm cool with saying look at me,
as long as once people
are looking at you go
now look at them.
So-
Right, right, okay.
That's a great way.
You have to be practical
about that, right?
That's a great way of thinking of it.
I like that, because I'm always...
and I also think it's,
be willing to try things,
have them work, not
work, but just move on.
It's that fear that a lot of
people have of making a mistake
or looking silly that
gets discussed a lot now,
which is try and if you make a mistake,
or if some of your friends check you
and say "yeah, that wasn't quite it.
Nice try, but that wasn't quite it,"
don't overreact and get
defensive, try again.
Yeah, fail better, I mean,
I'm not sure whose the quote is,
I had a discussion with Eddie Escalad,
and if he wants to text
in, he can tell us,
but, yeah, I think it's
try, fail, fail better.
Just keep at it, it's
too important to dip out,
and especially because you
get beat up on Twitter,
or wherever, that's not
really the barometer
by which we should be judging
how we should be acting,
although I understand it can influence us.
But we just have to
continue to ring the bell
and, like you said, and sometimes
it's not the perfect way,
but you just gotta keep ringing it.
Yeah, I always think this has
been something that's been,
this issue has plagued our country
for a couple of hundred years,
it is the defining stain on our country
that we need to get
better, we need to resolve,
and so, if some embarrassment on Twitter
is the price that you pay, so what?
Suck it up.
Yeah.
Suck it up, suck it up.